also wir haben echt so viele
konstruktion und sogar eine sache die
drinnen dieses winters ist so winterlich
und was als das ist so geil
also ich mag dieses bio minen gericht
ich gern vor allem weil es auch zu
selten ist und ich euch nun jetzt
einzieht vorstelle wo ihr das quasi
einfach hingehen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren zieht vorstellung in der
minecraft version 1.7 2 und zwar die
welt kann ich eben löschen
und zwar ist es ein zieht um in die oder
mündet in das eis spike bei um zu kommen
bzw in die eiszapfen tundra dam dam
jetzt denkt euch natürlich was das ist
einfach nur mal ein bier zu kommen man
kommt nicht mal direkte das bms ist
einfach nun zieht wo ich herausgefunden
habe was die koordinaten sind um in
dieses eiszapfen zu kommen und zwar der
sid - 1993 2 1 0 0 2 4 794 25.06.10 also
wir sind nicht direkt in diesem biom das
wäre zu schön sondern dieses biom ist
wirklich sehr sehr selten dieses mit dem
ganzen packeis türmen und alles was neu
hinzugefügt wurde
meine haare sind karg immer noch immer
noch am besten wasser und zwar ist bunt
hier ca hier so'n ebenso einfahren und
so was alles in der nähe von sondern von
lava dingsbums dort ihr müsst euch nicht
zu dem lahm allerdings umstellen ich
mache jetzt einfach mal damit ihr seht
weil das sollte man endlich erkennt ihr
solltet ihr wundervolles born kommt er
einfach hierhin ihr könnt euch auch das
ist scheißegal wieder hinstellt und die
gibt einfach ein / tp 104 81 und 411 und
dann klickt ihr einfach ändern könnt
doch tp ihren namen schreiben und dann
wenn im creative lab möglich schnell
fliegen weil sonst fällt ihr einfach
daraus der welt ihr geht das ja da an
der y koordinaten feilt und der falt-
und erfand und am besten einfach pflegen
damit ihr dann auf einer höhe seit und
dann regeneriert sich langsam die welt
und dann sehen wir schon davor nämlich
nach vorne nach vorne da vorne startet
die eiszapfen andere als es das tourer
oder dietrich ob die tundra oder
schriften die kommentare
und es ist echt das geilste biom finde
ich mittlerweile neben der savanne weil
wir haben einfach dieses pack also ich
finde es war immer so kacke weil es
wirklich nicht es hat nicht so wirklich
diese sättigung und dieses pack es hat
halt einfach diese sättigung oder das
ist einfach einmal geld also was hier
wirklich so viel konstruktionen sind da
hinten haben wir so ein komisches
türmchen könnte man diesen durchfliegen
also es ist echt so schwer zu bekommen
dahinter wir wissen dass das ihr sohn
boss thomas hecks hier also wir haben
echt so viele konstruktion und sogar
eine sache hier drinnen dieses
winterhalter es ist so winterlich und
was also ist so geil
also ich mag dieses bio minen gericht
ich gern vor allem weil es oft nur
selten ist und ich euch nun jetzt
vorstelle wo ihr das quasi einfach
hingehen können wenn euch irgendwie sagt
hey kennst du das land und region
ich war noch nicht da ich hab von craft
das video gesehen was los
also es ist sehr klein aber wir haben
wenigstens etwas und ich meine für sowas
winterlich ist das ist allerdings auch
dass ein anderer berg und ich möchte so
was winterliches oder so was man ja
eventuell im winter machen könnte soll
ich übrigens wieder diese six kraft
machen also christmas kraft das habe ich
letztes jahr gemacht und das hab ich
dann bei der heftigen mir abgebrochen
weil das bei mir total blöd war wegen
klausuren und sonders anders nicht das
nicht hingekriegt habe aber wir sagen
würde das ist doch voll holen macht das
doch mal wieder also chris muss kraft so
ein projekt so wo ich einfach so in der
schnee welt zu ein paar sachen bau und
über themen quatschen dann könnt ihr
jetzt einfach schreiben außerdem hier
das sieht extrem gerne was ist das da
unten
ach das ist einfach es jetzt nicht
geladen das ganz normal ist als aber
auch so cool sondern ein kleines
flüsschen so also ich denke wenn ich
hier drin wäre in diesem einen dieser
eiszapfen tun was wo würde ich mich hin
bauen
ich glaube sogar ich würde mich hier
einfach hin bauen hier oben drauf
einfach so dass ich alles im blick hätte
oder so das wäre auf jeden fall hammer
geil ich finde das ist einfach so ein
bio man einfach das ist ein ganz
normales extreme hitze mit bäumen nur
anstatt halt mit pak als anstellen
wollen wir das sieht echt alles aus wie
bäume ich finde das sieht alles aus wie
bäume irgendwie weiß nicht ich fand das
sieht anders aus
das könnten einfach bäume sein wenn das
wenn das dich eben wenn das einfach
bäume werden wäre es einfach wie so ein
extremes bei sven thiemann extreme
eltern müssen einfach nochmals biom halt
einfach nochmal na gut freude wenn es
euch gefallen hat und dem ihr weiteres
ii vorstellung wollt könnt ihr einfach
den daumen nach oben drücken das wird
mir zeigen dass ihr das feiert und je
mehr wollte und ihr könnt noch weiterhin
zieht es in die kommentare schreiben
und dann will ich sagen wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder schauer